abolishing slavery by constitutional
provision settles the fate for all
coming time
not only of the millions now in bondage
but of unborn
millions to come president abraham
lincoln portrayed by actor daniel day
lewis would eventually win the day he
signed the 13th amendment abolishing
slavery in 1865.
and he did it in february
that would lead to the black history
month we celebrate each year and it's
thanks in part to the efforts of a
former enslaved person richard robert
wright senior
wright's own life story is just what
this month is meant to honor during the
spanish-american war he was the
highest-ranking african-american officer
the first to serve as u.s army paymaster
late in life he enrolled at the
university of pennsylvania's prestigious
wharton school of business and founded
the first black-owned northern bank
a promoter of black education he founded
what is now savannah state university
sled dawson is the school's director of
leadership and authority on right why
don't we know more about this man how is
he not stoked in the annals of
african-american history and the likes
of a sajorna truth or
or harriet tubman or w.e.b dubois i
think if we really look out there you'll
find there's a bunch of richard r rights
and i would say even that he helped
create a bunch of future ritual rights
and that these were people who genuinely
wanted to make a difference for their
communities wherever they were after a
lifetime of achievement wright had one
more goal to make february 1st the day
of lincoln's historic signing national
freedom day in 1948 a year after
wright's death president truman signed
that into law the day was later
designated black history day and meeting
up with negro history week established
by historian carter g woodson eventually
expanded into black history month tell
me this what do you think he would be
most proud of he would be very proud of
our students
his students
after they graduated the things they did
in their communities when they went back
home or to wherever they went and how
they left that legacy there and so you
know savannah state university one of
the key things that we do is it gives us
an opportunity to apply what you learn
to real action to real practical
experiences and we try to make those
connections today just like you did back
then
so mr wright worked his way up became a
college president was a college
president for 30 years then at 67 went
to philly enrolled at wharton got his
business degree and then started the
first bank the first black bank in the
north and then guess what
made it through the depression with five
million dollars in assets something like
a half a billion dollars today he was
just a young man a youngster at 67.
i think a lot of people don't know much
about him or anything i was just going
to say an important reason to tell those
stories and father of nine